there's a handful of subtle references
to films real-world events and even the
silent art of mime lurking and Joker's
grim and gritty Gotham City if you're
still reeling from the violence and
drama of Arthur flex tragic journey keep
watching to learn about the little
things you might have missed if you know
one piece of trivia about the Joker it's
probably that he was originally inspired
not by the playing card from which he
took his name but by gwyn plane the main
character of the 1928 silent film the
man who laughs in the movie twin plane
played by German actor conrad veidt is a
child in the 17th century whose father
is killed by rival noblemen before they
put his father in the iron maiden though
they disfigure his face into a permanent
smile leaving him unable to ever truly
match his face to his emotions
also when Plains father was betrayed by
wait for it his jester whose Jess were
cruel and his smiles were false sound
like anyone you know
fittingly enough this cinematic
inspiration made its way back to the
movies and Joker the parallels to Arthur
flex medical condition which causes him
to compulsively laugh whenever he's
under stress are obvious it's more than
just the subtext though one Easter Egg
is a visual nod to a specific shot from
the man who laughs that recurs several
times and Joker throughout the film
Fleck forces a smile onto his face by
hooking his fingers into his mouth and
pulling upwards this is exactly the same
thing that the movies doctor does to
demonstrate Wynn claims condition
perhaps more importantly is the fact
that Fleck does the same thing to a
young Bruce Wayne when he's trying to
get access to Thomas Wayne the lines
immediately after that shot in the man
who laughs explained that they did it so
that Gwen clean would laugh forever at
his fool of a father given the dynamic
and play between Fleck in the Wayne's
there's actually way more to it than
just the supremely creepy act of putting
your hands in a child's mouth the man
who laughs isn't the only silent movie
to have its influence felt on Joker in
most versions of Gotham City it's
difficult to imagine a well publicized
showing of a famous Charlie Chaplin
comedy that seems to be attended solely
by billionaires as anything other than a
terrible idea
Joker however takes place before Gotham
is overrun with grandstanding theatrical
criminals who would strike at such a
gathering so it probably seemed like a
good idea
but I'm still it raises the question of
why modern times was chosen for a
sequence in the film and was featured so
prominently that we stopped to watch
Arthur Fleck as he watches one of its
most famous gags there's an obvious
level of course the scene in question
involves Chaplin's character
rollerskating blindfolded nearly falling
over a ledge into a precipitous fall a
pretty on the nose reinforcement of
Fleck as a man teetering on the edge of
sanity if you're familiar with the rest
of modern times though you'll realize
that some of its themes are Easter eggs
mirroring the ones we're seeing play out
for Gotham City
this is after all a film where Chaplin
as the [ __ ] is dealing with a desperate
economic situation finding himself
literally chewed up and spat out by the
machinery of heavy industry even more
telling is the scene where he's arrested
and sent to jail before being pardoned
only to argue that he'd rather stay in
jail than go back out and face the
alternative that's a sentiment that's
echoed and Joker by Brian Tyree Henry in
his role as a file clerk at arkham state
hospital who tells Arthur that some
people are better off locked up there
than out on the increasingly dangerous
streets of Gotham City saying that
director Todd Phillips was inspired by
Martin Scorsese and Joker is sort of
like saying that life on Earth is
inspired by the Sun there is a very
significant amount of taxi driver in the
DNA of Joker's broader plot points form
Arthur getting the handgun from his
co-worker Thomas Waynes political
ambitions and the grimy feel of Gotham
City it's not the only Scorsese picture
in play though perhaps unsurprisingly
1983's the King of Comedy had a huge
influence on Joker to the point where
it's worth your time to watch just to
catch everything that's going on see if
you can spot the connections here Robert
De Niro stars as Rupert Pupkin an
aspiring stand-up comedian obsessed with
talk-show host Jerry Langford Pupkin
often has vivid fantasies which are
never clearly delineated for the
audience of being on Langford show and
even being friends with Langford himself
I really appreciate you meeting me for
lunch I know how busy you are and I'm
tired
what a French forger eventually his
obsession leads him to kidnap Langford
holding him for ransom until he's
allowed to be a guest on the show where
he tells a few jokes about his crime
confessing to the audience in the guise
of a stand-up routine if you've seen
Joker you should be experiencing a
powerful feeling of deja vu right now
but the exclamation point on the easter
egg comes in DeNiro himself being cast
as Murry Franklin the talk show host
with whom Fleck is obsessed naturally he
winds up being caught up in Flex madness
even accidentally giving him the name
Joker the parallels are strong even if
Joker turns out to be significantly more
homicidal than Pupkin was the motif of
Arthur Fleck dancing recurs throughout
Joker from his halting oedipal waltz
with his mother all the way to the final
moments of the film but there's one
moment where it seems different after
his first trio of kills when he's
collecting himself in a dimly lit
bathroom flex feets sweep across the
floor leading his whole body into a long
routine the thing is it doesn't look
like the dancing we see elsewhere in the
film it's more fluid and seems more
theatrically performative so what's the
deal you can debate why Arthur chooses
this moment for a graceful dance
sequence but in the real world the
filmmakers could be using the scene to
evoke the fluid movements of legendary
French mime Marcel Marceau if that
sounds like a long shot that's because
it is but consider this potential easter
egg what if Marceau's most famous
performances was the mask maker in which
he pantomimed putting on a series of
masks changing his expression to match
the climax of the piece comes when
Marceau finds that a mask depicting pure
white eye joy has become stuck on his
face he struggles to remove it trying to
peel off what seems like his own skin as
his body contorts with pain and
depression all while his face remains
locked in the painted smile of a clown
if that doesn't sound like what's going
on in Joker then we don't know what does
this might be surprising considering
that it's a movie about the Joker
you know the bad guy from the Batman
comic books but Joker doesn't really
have a lot of specific references to the
comics other than the major characters
there aren't really any superheroes or
villains referenced in the film unless
you count the offhand mention of super
cats being a deep cut reference to
streaky there's no hint of Harley Quinn
no haha siendo or Jo
and sadly Arthur Fleck never even
proclaims that it's time for the Joker's
five-way revenge there is one major
exception though well it's pretty
clearly in homage to King of Comedy it's
easy to argue that the entire climax of
the film is an easter egg referencing
one of the most influential Batman
comics of all time the Dark Knight
Returns in the third issue of Frank
Miller's 80s classic The Joker appears
as a guest on a talk show the scene and
Joker isn't a direct homage to the
comics seeing as how the circumstances
of the stories are so different but
there is one clear reference you may
have missed it's one of the show's other
guests dr. Sally whose few lines
indicate that she's a sex therapist
along the lines of the real-life dr.
Ruth Westheimer a similar figure also
appears in the Dark Knight Returns as
does the theatrical and incredibly
creepy kiss that Joker plants on her as
he enters the scene Joker marks the
fifth time that a live-action mr. J has
been featured on the big screen the
first four times 1966 1989 The Dark
Knight and Suicide Squad if you're
keeping score at home all featured very
different designs but that all drew from
the same source
you'd never confuse Cesar Romero's Joker
with Heath Ledger's but they both got
green hair and purple suits and even
Jared Leto's purple snakeskin coat keeps
the color scheme going Joker on the
other hand breaks with tradition rather
than the traditional purple Arthur flex
emergence as the Joker comes with a
slightly different look the green hair
is there and the traditional three-piece
suit but rather than purple and green
it's more of a burgundy it's a small
difference and the most likely
explanation is that todd phillips
joaquin phoenix and costume designer
mark bridges wanted their take on the
character to be visually distinct from
the others which was probably a good
idea given a few strong similarities to
Heath Ledger's look but there is one
place where you can find this color
scheme on a past version of the Joker
and it probably isn't where you expect
back in 1990 the Kenner toy company was
riding the wave of the 89 Batman movie
when they released sky escaped Joker
it's not quite the same costume the vest
and shirt colors are switched but the
colour of the jacket is shockingly
similar to what wound up in theater is
29 years later does this mean that there
was a draft of Joker in which Phoenix
flew around
Sky escape Joker's backpack helicopter
probably not but hey you never know
release the sky escape cut Warner
Brothers Joker pulls a big portion of
its aesthetic from New York City in the
mid-80s and not just because it's a
poking the grimy crime-ridden streets a
taxi driver in the king of comedy
there are real-life incidents forming
the background for the events playing
out on the screen including the massive
spike in crime that accompanied the
crack epidemic and a garbage strike
that's based on similar sanitation
worker strikes in New York like one that
lasted 17 days in 1981 the one incident
most heavily referenced in the plot of
Joker is the 1984 shooting of four men
in a subway car by Bernie gets gets
claimed that he was defending himself
from a robbery and was initially dubbed
the subway vigilante by media before he
turned himself in he was also referred
to as the death wish fish Lanie a
reference to the popular revenge movie
starring Charles Bronson many New
Yorkers as well as people following the
story from elsewhere were supportive of
Getz's actions viewing them as a
justified response to the seemingly
unchecked rise of violent crime
vigilantes showing up every now and then
I'll have a good healthy reminder to
some of the lawbreakers eventually
though public opinion turned against him
largely because of the view that gets
had been racially motivated all four men
shop I gets where black gets himself was
not which was supported by racist
statements gets had made in the past
some of his statements also came off as
needlessly violent and even creepy while
there were plenty of people willing to
indulge in Deathwish style revenge
fantasies those are the kind of
statements that make them think you
might not be all that stable to begin
with it's no accident then that Arthur's
transformation into Joker begins with
shooting his assailants on a subway
train and that he only stops shooting
because he runs out of bullets
or that his actions are sensationalized
by the media and approved of by others
in Gotham City check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]